hi everyone
so this video aims to provide insight on
how to structure your day and week in
order to get the most out of it
at the moment i'm working on multiple
projects and i identified that
structure and proper evaluation of
psychological and physiological
parameters
is the key to ensuring a productive
schedule without structure
and without understanding your mind and
your body your chances of enjoying a
full and
balanced lifestyle decrease dramatically
and your motivation and your mood suffer
in respect
regardless of how busy you are in your
life the schedule i'll suggest today
will prove
quite helpful i decided to name it the
da vinci schedule because
it is inspired by the legend himself
leonardo da vinci was celebrated
polymath
and he has famously said that just as a
well-filled day brings blessed sleep
so a well-employed life brings a blessed
death
this addict has had a major impact on my
life along with another one from the
great psychiatrist irvin yalum
that reads death anxiety is greater than
those who feel
that they have lived an unfulfilled life
so
in my pursuit of a fulfilled and well
examined life
they both inspired me to keep
re-engineering my schedule
in order to make it more creative
purposeful and fun
the davinci schedule is the result of
this process
the main conundrums that davinci
schedule tries to tackle are
how to be creative and enter flow on a
daily basis
how to not allow interruptions to ruin
your flow
how to stop procrastinating and get
things done
how to make sure you don't experience
burnout
how to make sure you socialize enough
and balance work with play
the main idea behind it is to allow
yourself enough fluidity in your
schedule without getting overwhelmed by
a
profuse amount of tasks here's how it
works
a lot of people suggest that the
planning should start on the first day
of the week
so you can allow yourself some time to
recover from the weekend
in my opinion that is wrong the planning
should start on sunday
evening that is because monday should be
your deep dive day
think of monday as the equivalent of
your early hours in the morning
but for the week in the morning your
mind is rested and it can amaze you with
the productivity it can deliver
your early hours for the week are monday
tuesday
and wednesday in order to take advantage
of that parallel you need to plan your
tasks on sunday
so every sunday evening around seven to
eight pm
sit at your desk reflect on your weekend
focus
and start planning your week from my
point of view this is what your weekly
and daily plan should look like
in rough terms so let me elaborate
firstly we need to use the following
categorization for the daily plan
morning routine deep work admin work
fitness networking and socializing
play
i decided to divide deep work into those
two categories because
deep work is a spectrum that spectrum is
susceptible to its individual's
preferences
for instance i have two activities that
require deep work
writing and video editing due to my
electrical engineering background
i find anything related to technology
quite easy so for me
video editing is easier than writing
therefore video editing is treated as
soft tip work and writing as intensive
work
in essence what this means is that
depending on how you evaluate your deep
work tasks
the intense ones need to be carried out
monday to wednesday
and the soft ones thursday to friday
admin work includes things like email
document organization
ordering supplies scheduling meetings
etc
in short everything that can be done by
a personal assistant but
when you can't afford one you need to
complete yourself these tasks are very
important and oftentimes can take more
time than expected
therefore it is crucial to evaluate via
trial and error the time required to
complete them and plan accordingly
[Music]
when you work in a company meetings are
a crucial element of your schedule
yes they are important and in my
experience they can definitely improve
team building
and project flow but more often than not
they don't add value to your working
flow so my rule for meetings is called
the early late rule what this rule
proposes is that
in order to ensure that a meeting won't
interrupt your deep workflow
meetings need to be scheduled either
early in the morning or late in the
afternoon
that is before 10 am and after 2pm
[Music]
fitness for me includes cardio and
weightlifting or body weight training
i run for two or three miles almost
every morning and i work out at home
three to four times per week running is
incorporated in my morning routine which
i will discuss in a bit
as far as my workout is concerned i like
to work out right after work in order to
avoid late evening fatigue
i make sure to eat something around 4 pm
and i work out around
6 pm in terms of organization workouts
occur
usually monday wednesday and friday and
maybe once during the weekend
i like to keep it like that because it
helps me plan meetups and other events
throughout the week
at least one or two times per week i
like to attend meetups and other
networking events
i consider this important because it
allows me to challenge myself
to socialize to refine my thought
articulation and help me explore
different mindsets and live philosophies
the meetups don't necessarily need to be
business related
they can be philosophy meetups
literature meetups or even
fitness meetups the idea behind this
approach is that
you allow yourself to stay connected
increase your social reach
and also satisfy your need for belonging
this is a time where you can fool around
and indulge in pleasures
these pleasures can vary from reading
and watching youtube videos
to playing video games and going for
drinks with friends
it depends solely on you and your
personal preferences but
my experience has shown that planning
can help you enjoy that process even
more
for instance i like to take some friends
and arrange with them during the week in
advance
or i like to plan a movie on wednesday
evening or i like to schedule a specific
time where i practice some of my hobbies
like
music learning new languages or playing
call of duty
the task list is the most powerful
productivity tool
it really encapsulates the essence of
productivity and helps you declutter
your brain
every day in the morning write down your
five most important tasks and categorize
them effectively
one should include deep work and the
rest should belong to the admin work
domain
flow occurs when you immerse yourself in
uninterrupted deep work
a trick to get there is to listen to
music you enjoy preferably with a beat
that can help brainwaves you know
coordinate and stimulate focus
and shut down all external stimuli like
email
phone and irrelevant browser tabs you
need a good 15 minutes to enter flow and
you can work up to four hours in that
state
therefore i suggest working in that mode
from 10 am
to 2 pm
i have experimented with morning
routines quite extensively and i have
come to the conclusion that
a morning routine can be something very
simple but also
something quite elaborate its goal is to
focus on activities that can galvanize
you motivate you
inspire you help you focus and give you
strength to continue your day fully
energized
for the purposes of this video i will
propose something quite straightforward
but also very effective
so you start your day by waking up
around 6 30
to 7 a.m you run for one or two miles
then you take a cold shower then you
take good care of your skin
if you fast don't eat anything if you
don't fast
cook yourself a big and healthy
breakfast read a book for 30 minutes
read the news or things that interest
you for 20 minutes meditate for 10 to 15
minutes
continue with the rest of your day
at the moment i have to take care of
many projects which means that
i also work during the weekends that
however doesn't mean that i allow myself
to burn out
i consider going out a very healthy
habit and at least once a week i like to
go to a club or a bar
if i go out till late i sleep for at
least eight hours and i wake up
repeating my usual morning routine
then i spend time immersing into
activities that i like
that might include working on projects
surfing
on youtube meeting with friends etc in
any case
your weekend is the time where
everything is allowed and anything you
do
should be stress free
bringing structure to your weekly and
daily schedule is similar to
decluttering your personal space
when you eliminate clutter your mind
perceives your environment
as an organized area that allows it to
analyze patterns in a more effective way
that way you can enjoy an effectual
daily schedule and go to bed
fulfilled just like da vinci so
here is the structure and here's to that
wonderful man leonardo da vinci
may he always be an inspiration to all
of us
hi everyone hope you enjoyed today's
video as always don't forget to like
subscribe
turn on notifications and also let me
know in the comments what is your main
obstacle when it comes
to planning your day and also your week
also i want you to know that i have
written a very detailed ebook and this
is called 30 challenges
30 days zero excuses and it is very
relevant to today's topic
i wrote it initially for me because i
wanted to challenge myself and push
myself
for 30 days to adopt habits evangelized
by the most
influential figures in the personal
development world
in the book i analyze habits like
meditation small talk
power posing journaling sleeping and
many more that can help you enjoy more
productive purposeful
and healthy life it has been read by
thousands of people around the world
and all of them have experienced
significant changes in the way they live
their lives
you can check it out here or the in the
description below
i really suggest you to embark on this
30 day adventure you have nothing to
lose
and so much to gain again thanks for
watching take care
see you soon adrian now
you